so you wanna be cool like me this guy
well let me tell you waiting come and
easy boy
you can't just walk up and be like hey
I'm cool I know what you're thinking how
did he get so cool
how did he get so fresh and how does he
stay so humble instructional videos
[Music]
then sit on a couch or a chair upside
down in this position your chin is the
performers nose oh yeah making you
upside down face look like it's really
singing that's a little teeth which you
lower lip and expose your upper teeth
with your upper lip then cut loose this
will take some practice but you'll soon
be showing off the heads to your friends
like this long
[Music]
always looks so good boy except it's DJ
car oh my god oh my god number one why
does he look like me number two why is
he cringy like me number three is that
my dad that's my dad he's gonna talk
about beatboxing please please talk
about beatboxing beatbox
- I have my own theme music when I walk
right he has his own theme music when he
walks he has his own feet Merrick thank
you this guy's so [ __ ] slick this is
like the cooler version of me just look
at it I have my own theme music when I
want who has a theme stung so for when
they walk I bet you don't have I been
Xterra is not naturally blonde like mine
though and I walk in the street I'm
looking good
what who is this guy and why is he me
get away from me what the [ __ ] what is
happening what is happening I can't now
here's how you can make your own beat
box out okay first practice doing a buck
sound explosively as you can right here
it is alright alright what else
try that now make a hard case out in the
back of your mouth now put the two
together and you get this
now you supposed to do it together what
the [ __ ]
see I think it's party time
[Music]
I think it's party time
[Music]
right there break it down now to me now
ago now
[Music]
yeah I've learned I've learned so much
already honestly like I feel indulged I
feel like I feel like my life is better
now here's a quick one you can do while
waiting for your hamburger to be served
all right fine I've been looking for a
long time for a quick one
when my hamburger is getting served okay
let's see why what else do you got cuz
the string trick I don't think you can
beat the string trick there's string
trick it ah [ __ ] it scared me and the
Big Finish tada Trinko down the paper so
take from the top and you crinkle up
from the bottom
oh you get a nice tight coil why that's
sexy porn music next you get a drop of
water or some other kind of beverage
drop on the straw work okay so our fans
watch out now ah dude I'm going to get a
breaker right [ __ ] now to try out
that spring worm [ __ ] gazettes that's
just not cool that's science cool he's
gonna banish it to theme here Wow
[Music]
how is he gonna do it I'm gonna show you
how to do this he's gonna show us how to
do it we are on this side of the stairs
or on this but there where's the stairs
it's not a stairs is it it's a hedge and
over there is somebody else and they
don't know what's going to happen and
what we're going to do is walk down the
head it just hit me like this is the
kind of [ __ ] that I remember too when I
was a kid like pre-internet
this is pre-internet area you would do
[ __ ] like this and it would be like dog
that is the coolest [ __ ] I have ever
seen today it's like hey have you seen
this gift like this we take the step
behind we bend the knee the body stays
straight we take another step we go down
a little further we take another step we
go down a little further until finally
we're down here now if you get down here
and you still have a ways to go you can
fake the rest of it with your upper body
and your head like this until you
disappear holy [ __ ] that's okay I gotta
try this I gotta try this I gotta try
this one
okay you know you don't see me now okay
hey guys it's me Felix
going downstairs I thought it'd look
cool I don't know whatever now the
secret to this one wait she didn't get
her
that's hilarious pinnacle of comedy door
face slam why have I not thought of that
I don't even have a door I need to
install a door but in front of you as
you exit so that you kick the door then
pretend that you've just walked into it
headfirst
now first practice this slowly and
carefully to get your timing right and
then add in a real loud so that you fool
everyone this is why parents are so
cringy aye they've been trained by these
people and make sure you're wearing your
shoes on this one that's so goofy that's
so crazy I need to practice
[Music]
how does he do now how did she do that
are they beside Syria huh pretend that
you have a dog pulling on your pant legs
now you position yourself behind the
door okay I can literally imagine like
myself like 12 watching this and
thinking like that's hilarious I gotta
try that and then you try it off and
then it's just a cringe thing ever and
then it's the kind of thing that you
regret literally your whole life
26 years old 27 you still remember that
one moment that you did this thing you
thought would be cool but it see really
just crunchy piece of [ __ ] and you look
like a [ __ ]
taking away but I don't know what is for
you wherever I go I always take my
bicycle horn with me wait a minute how
did do that hey in the sensory how Fonzo
the finger pulling of a long line of
finger contortions wait what is he doing
fine as it was about to perform the
amazing leader dangled the finger tango
now let's see that amazing feat quick'
in slow motion quickly in slow motion
okay
see how finds all the faders switches is
two index fingers to make this fabulous
feat work
[Music]
one two three to Garvey
[Music]